at the newbury showgrounds here in west
berkshire and this is where people first
started noticing a problem they'd taken
a lateral flow test and tested
positive on that they came here to a
government-run site had the pcr test and
then the pcr result was coming back
negative and this kept happening so an
investigation was launched nhs test and
trace have got involved and they've
discovered that there's no problem with
the kit there's no problem with this
site it is an issue with the laboratory
in wolverhampton it's called the immense
health clinic in wolverhampton that has
now been suspended 43 000 people
and their pcr tests affected by this we
have a statement uh through which is
from the dr will welfare his public
health incident director he says we've
recently seen a rising number of
positive uh lateral flow results
subsequently testing negative on pcr as
a result of our investigation and we're
working with nhs test and trace and the
company to determine the laboratory
technical issues which have led to
inaccurate pcr results so very
significant development this and very
embarrassing as well
yeah given the nature of the illness
ender i suppose it's it's too late for a
lot of people that would have been
having to self-isolate no point now is
there
no none whatsoever obviously nhs test
and trace will be getting in touch with
every single person affected but on the
wider issue of the pandemic that's
potentially 43 000 people mingling in
society
having
really tested positive for culvert
having been sent a pcr negative so it's
very very significant indeed